whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners-up police in
Rahway New Jersey who told this woman
that her naked snow sculpture had to be
covered up and it was like this bikini
top and sera and how about the beer
busting Pennsylvania State Police who
got drunk with power and conducted armed
raids on three Philadelphia bars owned
by these folks the alleged offense
selling unlicensed beer but there's only
one nanny of the month in this time it's
New York State Assemblyman Felix Ortiz a
new proposed bill would ban salt use in
New York restaurants Ortiz has cooked up
a bill that would stick restaurants with
a thousand dollar fine each time a shift
dare to sneak some of the white stuff
this bill will bring the escalating
health care costs down our country Mayor
Bloomberg is waging his own war on salt
but even Medellin Mike calls Ortiz's
plan ridiculous we are dressing an issue
that is a health problem in our country
check back next month for more examples
of busybodies minding your own business
you